I understand okay the quality of women
but I kept thinking why so this is the
average American chick why is it like
this and my second question was why are
men complaining about marriage so these
are men give them smiley face he's
saying they're saying don't ever get
married and I'm thinking why
why the legal system all of society is
catering towards women okay all of
society is basically pandering and
simping for women for example in the UK
If You Accuse your guy of a free lawyer
another example is free government
handouts for women in single month for
single mothers so we essentially have a
system that is paying women to be single
mothers so